ing again I just fining
Swish Video aboutal correctness resp
Challenge
ored
myes too easy on because I
stedare and of course easier
to
other now and I you can't have all
languages up at some phenomenal
Performance Level you you build up a
basic competence and and then if I were
to
devote some time to German which I would
love to have the time to
do you know reading on say politics and
accumulating that vocabulary
politische Korrektheit was heißt das das
also meine Meinung nach das B D es gibt
in unserer Gesellschaft in Deutschland
in Schweden in Kanada es gibt manche
Leute und diese Leute sind diese
sogenannte moralistisch oder ideologis
ideologische Elite und die sie glauben
also das sind Professoren in
Universitäten das sind Politiker das
sind Leute die schreiben für für für ze
und so sogenannte
intellektual Intelligenz ja und die
glauben dass die haben bestimmt was ist
richtig wie man soll sich ausdrücken und
und wenn man
nicht wenn man etwas anderes sagt dann
wird man sofort
als Rassist oder Faschist oder oder also
als
als also nicht akeptabel
äh erscheinen und das ist sehr viel äh
Druck und das hindert Leute das das
macht
so die Leute die haben eigene Meinung
und das sagen sie nur in die
zu Hause in die Küche oder wenn sie mit
Freunde zusammen sind und sie haben
trinken ein Glas Bier dann sagen sie
Dinge dass sie haben Angst zu sagen in
die Gesellschaft und ja ich glaube das
ist nicht gesund ich glaube wir sollchen
wir sollten die Möglichkeit haben unsere
Meinung zu ausdrücken
äh und
eine ein Beispiel zum also ein gute
Beispiel ich war am Ende November war
ich in Deutschland nach unserer Reise
dass ich habe eine Reise gemacht mit
meiner Frau wir waren in Italien und war
am November vier Tagen vier Tagen waren
wir in Deutschland München und ich habe
diese Buch gekauft weil diese Buch ist
ein Bestseller in Deutschland und das
ist auch ein sehr interessante Buch weil
es es es es ich habe sehr viel gelernt
gelernt über die deutsche Gesellschaft
na ich kann nicht sagen dass ich stimme
mit alle alles was er was diese til
geschreibt hat aber er hat sehr viel
Untersuchungen gemacht er ist sehr
ehrlich hat sehr viel Arbeit gemacht und
er
hat hat Sorgen über die Zukunft seines
Land das ist ein guter Mann das ist
nicht ein schlechter mann das ist kein
Rassist das ist kein nazist aber sofort
hat seine politische Partei die soziale
Sozialdemokraten sie haben sich sofort
haben sie sagt das wir nicht sind nicht
das ist er ist ich glaube er ist schon
nicht mehr Mitglied in diese
Sozialdemokratische Partei und andere
Leute auch haben alle haben sagt das ist
schlecht man darf nicht so schreiben und
er hat sehr viel Problem gemacht gehabt
ich finde es das das ist man kann ein
andere Buch schreiben und und alle seine
Erfindungen kann man dann gegen
also andere Meinung
also schreiben oder oder oder sagen aber
warum darf man til sag als als äh viende
der die Gesellschaft machen das finde
ich sehr schlecht
z.B ich habe gelest also in ein Zeitung
in Deutschland das er hat gesagt dass
alle Juden
Teilen ein also dasselbe Gen Genin gen
glaube ich und das ist also das
ist furchtbar wie kann das wie kann man
das sagen weil in Deutschland das Thema
Genetik
äh Juden Deutschland es geht nicht man
kann nicht das alles in ein
ein Satz zusammen stellen es geht nicht
aber es gibt Juden die sagen dasselbe
das ist ist kein oder das ist wahr die
Wahrheit oder ist ist nicht die Wahrheit
und wenn es nicht die Wahrheit ist d
können können Sie andere Wahrheiten
also herausbringen aber aber ist kein
Grund äh diese Mann zu zu zu zu
attackieren und wir haben die diese
selbe Phänomen hier im Kanada ich bin
gegen
diese also viel multikulturalism ich
finde das ist nicht eine gute Strategie
das ist nicht eine gute Politik für
unser Land auch nicht gut für die
Immigranten ich finde es wird würde
besser sein wenn die Immigranten
integrieren wir wir können nicht die
dies diese Leute zwingen
aber wir haben in Kanada eine so die die
die die die wie sagt man die politically
correct die politisch korrekt Ideal das
soll Multikultur multikulturalism sein
wenn wir sind gegen multikulturalism
dann sind wir Amerikaner oder was aber
wir haben genauso viel Assimilation
Assimilation oder Integration in Kanada
als in in die USA das ist daselbe
Phänomen wir sind ein melting Part
genauso wie in USA aber wir haben diese
diese ideal ich für mich das ist nicht
wahr das ist nicht wahr wir sind wir
haben in die zweite dritte Generation
sind wir genauso m wie in die in die in
die Vereinigten Staaten aber wie das
darfen wir nicht sagen wir müssen sagen
wir sind
Multikultur und wenn wir wenn ich sage
ich bin gegen das und ich habe diese
Erfahrung gehacht ich war auf eine eine
Reunion und ich habe gesagt ich ich
finde das ist nicht eine gute Idee dann
big racist das war
unglaublich diese Reaktion und und ich
glaube diese Druck der die Leute sind
nicht sie haben nicht die Erlaubnis sie
haben nicht sie fühlen sich nicht in in
die Freiheit seine eigigen Meinung zu
ausdrucken
und es gibt sehr viele Beispiele und es
ist immer so dass wir verteidigen die
Minderheiten okay so wenn ein
äh christlicher
Prest also sagt ich bin gegen die die
die Ehe
äh also die die das
homosexuell Leute sich
verheiraten kann ich bin dagegen sagt
ein evangelische Pastor oh das kann man
nicht sagen das ist schlecht aber wenn
ein Imam oder
irgendwer von einer sogenannte
Minderheit äh Kultur sagt das ne das
geht es das ist schon multikulturalism
er darf das sagen wir haben keine Ahnung
was die alle Leute sagen in der moskee
aber das ist es gibt sehr viele
Dinge gegen Juden gegen homosexuell aber
es ist es kommt nie in die in die
Zeitungen aber wenn ein christlicher
Pastor sagt etwas dann ist es sehr stark
ich meine wir sollen in unsere Länder
wir haben das Recht unserer
mehrheitultur zu verteidigen und
äh äh politische Korrektheit äh es es
schafft die Gefahr dass wir werden
äh eventuell
unser
Rechte in unser eigene Land verloren und
und ich glaubeor sarosa hat ein bisschen
darüber äh erwähnt in seinem Buch und äh
ich finde dass wir wir sollen mehr
Freiheit haben und weniger äh politisch
ktag haben und das mit alle meiner
Fehler auf Deutsch ist meine Meinung auf
Wiedersehen